it is not a new problem but it's a
serious one people stealing packages
right off people's doorsteps many call
them porch pirates and they seem to come
out in full force over the holiday
season sasha loftis spoke with one woman
who says a whole lot of people in her
area have been hit she joins us now live
with the very latest sasha
yes brian the idea of it is pretty
unsettling having someone steal
something you just bought right off your
front porch now the woman i spoke with
tonight says she wants to warn others so
it doesn't happen to them this is the
one where she
actually picks the package up claudia
terkaz is frustrated as she shows us
this video
of her things being stolen in broad
daylight it's really unfortunate she's
one of many who was hit by what she
calls a serial thief in her henderson
neighborhood as she says a woman in a
white car has been driving up and
snatching packages off front porches
it's heartbreaking because a lot of
people work hard for their money
heartbreaking but unfortunately all too
common as what many call porch pirates
come out in full force during the
holiday season according to a study by
cnr research 43 percent of people in
2020 reported having a package stolen
right from their front door i think it's
why it kind of is you know kind of hits
more
to the heart or to home just because it
is the holidays metro police provide
tips every year like having things
delivered to work using an amazon locker
service or buying a porch guard device i
think if we become more vigilant
of each other in the neighborhood i
think less it's less likely to happen
but claudia believes neighbors have the
power to help each other
and fight back against anyone trying to
steal their holiday spirit just stop
stealing people's stuff
if you see anyone stealing a package off
of someone's front door you can call
your local police department or crime
stoppers to report that anonymously now
as for that list i mentioned from metro
police to keep your packages on your
porch safe we have that entire thing on
our website eight newsnow dot com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now